[Music]
next generation sequencing or
ngs is a powerful platform that has
enabled the sequencing of thousands to
millions of dna molecules simultaneously
this powerful tool is revolutionizing
fields such as personalized medicine
genetic diseases and clinical
diagnostics by offering a high
throughput option with the capability to
sequence multiple individuals at the
same time
sanger sequencing first developed in the
1900s
is the gold standard for dna sequencing
and it is still used today
extensively for routine sequencing
applications and to validate
ngs data it utilizes a high fidelity dna
dependent polymerase to generate a
complementary copy to a single stranded
dna template
in each reaction a single primer
complementary to the template
initiates a dna synthesis reaction from
its three prime end
deoxynucleotides or simply nucleotides
are added one after the other in a
template-dependent manner
each reaction also contains a mixture of
four dideoxynucleotides
one for each dna base these dye
deoxynucleotides resemble the dna
monomers enough to allow incorporation
into the growing strand
however they differ from natural
deoxynucleotides in two ways
one they lack a three prime hydroxyl
group which is required for further dna
extension resulting in chain termination
once incorporated in the dna molecule
and two each dioxide nucleotide has a
unique fluorescent dye attached to it
allowing for automatic detection of the
dna sequence
as a result many copies of different
length dna fragments are generated in
each reaction
terminated at all of the nucleotide
positions of the template molecule by
one of the dye deoxynucleotides
the reaction mixtures are loaded on the
sequencing machine
either manually onto slab gels or
automatically with capillaries
and are electrophoresed to separate the
dna molecules by size
the dna sequence is read through the
fluorescent emission of the dye
deoxynucleotide as it flows through the
gel
modern-day sanger sequencing instruments
use capillary-based automated
electrophoresis
which typically analyzes 8-96 sequencing
reactions simultaneously
next generation sequencing systems have
been introduced in the past decade that
allow for massively parallel sequencing
reactions
these systems are capable of analyzing
millions or even billions of sequencing
reactions at the same time
although different machines have been
developed with various differing
technical details
they all share some common features one
sample preparation all next generation
sequencing platforms require
a library obtained either by
amplification or ligation with custom
adapter sequences
two sequencing machines each library
fragment is amplified on a solid surface
with covalently attached dna
linkers that hybridize the library
adapters
this amplification creates clusters of
dna each originating from a single
library fragment
each cluster will act as an individual
sequencing reaction
and three data output
each machine provides the raw data at
the end of the sequencing run
this raw data is a collection of dna
sequences that were generated at each
cluster
the differences between the different
next generation sequencing platforms lie
mainly in the technical details of the
sequencing reaction
and can be categorized in four groups
pyrosequencing
sequencing by synthesis sequencing by
ligation
and ion semiconductor sequencing
in pyrosequencing the sequencing
reaction is monitored through the
release of a pyrophosphate during each
nucleotide incorporation
the released pyrophosphate is used in a
series of chemical reactions resulting
in the generation of light
light emission is detected by a camera
which records the appropriate sequence
of the cluster
the sequencing proceeds by incubating
one base at a time
measuring the light emission degrading
the unincorporated bases
and then the addition of another base
this technology is capable of generating
large read lengths
much comparable to the read length of
sanger sequencing
however high reagent cost and high error
rate over strings of six or more
homopolymers have reduced its
applications
sequencing by synthesis utilizes the
step-by-step incorporation of reversibly
fluorescent and terminated nucleotides
for dna sequencing
and is used by the alumina ngs platforms
all four nucleotides are added to the
sequencing chip at the same time
after nucleotide incorporation the
remaining dna bases are washed away the
fluorescent signal is red at each
cluster
and the terminator group are then
cleaved and washed away
this process is repeated until the
sequencing reaction is complete
this system is able to overcome the
disadvantages of the pyrosequencing
system by only incorporating a single
nucleotide at a time
however as the sequencing reaction
proceeds the error rate of the machine
also increases this is due to incomplete
removal of the fluorescent signal which
leads to higher background noise levels
sequencing by ligation is different from
the other two methods
since it does not utilize a dna
polymerase to incorporate nucleotides
instead it relies on 16 8 mare
oligonucleotide probes
each with one of four fluorescent dyes
attached to its five prime end that are
legated to one another
each eight mare consists of two probe
specific bases
and six degenerate bases the sequencing
reaction commences by binding of the
primer to the adapter sequence
and then hybridization of the
appropriate probe
this hybridization of the probe is
guided by the two probe specific bases
and upon annealing is legated to the
primer sequence through a dna ligase
unbound oligonucleotides are washed away
the signal is detected and recorded
after that the fluorescent signal
along with the last three bases of the
eight mere probe are cleaved
and then the next cycle commences after
approximately seven cycles of ligation
the dna strand is denatured and another
sequencing primer
offset by one base from the previous
primer is used to repeat these steps
in total five sequencing primers are
used
the major disadvantage of this
technology is the very short sequencing
reads generated
ion semiconductor sequencing utilizes
the release of hydrogen ions during the
sequencing reaction to detect the
sequence of a cluster
each cluster is located directly above a
semiconductor transistor which is
capable of detecting changes in the ph
of the solution
during nucleotide incorporation a single
hydrogen ion is released into the
solution
and it is detected by the semiconductor
the sequencing reaction itself proceeds
similarly to pyrosequencing but at a
fraction of the cost
in order to be able to showcase and
compare the different technical aspects
of each of the above technologies
the number of coverage that each run
generates when sequencing the whole
human
mouse arabidopsis thaliana
an e coli genome are calculated and
presented here
the presented data is based on the most
powerful machines of each technology
for whole genome sequencing data to be
useful a minimum of 30x coverage
is required as it can be seen the
pyrosequencing method is only able to
sequence the e coli genome at enough
coverage to result in valid data
the sequencing by synthesis method which
is the most popular method currently on
the market
is able to generate hundreds of coverage
per run
in fact with this machine it is possible
to sequence 15 individuals within 3.5
days
the sequencing by ligation method also
generates enough coverage for all
genomes to be used
however it isn't capable of generating
nearly as much output
as the illumina hysec machines the ion
proton machine is used mostly in
clinical setting
because it is able to provide a
sufficient size output within two hours
in conclusion ngs technologies are
increasingly being adopted by
researchers
and are bestowing various benefits in
terms of massive parallel cyclic array
sequencing
the common advantage of all the
platforms is the quantity and quality of
large amount of data generated
the decreasing costs of dna sequencing
by many orders are fascinating
given the current status of certain
challenges associated with ngs
it is anticipated that ngs technologies
will become as widespread as microarray
it is also expected that the challenges
will shift from mastering the technology
to how best it can go for extracting
biologically meaningful information from
large amounts of data generated by ngs
it is quite obvious that these
technologies are incredibly promising in
terms of research
and clinical applications
[Music]
you